good afternoon welcome to our workshop
today where the results of our recent
gender diversity and fibre survey will
be presented
my name is sue waglianoni my day job is
senior director of international
marketing at commscope but i've had the
pleasure of being a board member of the
ftth council europe now for the past 18
months
for those that may not be familiar with
the council we've been in existence as
an organization for over 17 years
with a mission to advance ubiquitous
full fibre-based connectivity across
europe we're very proud of our
membership of over 150 companies who
benefit from the content that we produce
as an organization
some of the networking opportunities we
create and the relationships we have
with policy makers and regulators
next slide please
now parts of the content that i
referenced just then was a is a busy
series of webinars this being one of
those um they address topics core to the
industry our next session will be at the
end of january hosted by science who
will be presenting a telcos perspective
to planning and designing an integrated
ftth network so
one not to miss so do look out for the
invite and register your place to attend
that session next slide please
i get started we have some basic
housekeeping notes here to advise you
that you will be able to of course
access the replay as well as all of the
great material that will be presented
here today once the webinar has
concluded
we'd also love to share details of
future webinars with you um when they're
being hosted and of course you can opt
out of those if you no longer want to
receive those
and finally we know that this is a topic
that sometimes divides opinions so we
say don't be shy feel free to ask any
questions you may have and we'll
hopefully have some time at the end to
work our way through those
next slide
let's get on to it shall we so the
survey itself was undertaken by the
women in fiber committee with the
support of the ftth council europe in
september this year
we're a very young committee and what we
felt was important to do was to qualify
um the best the baseline on gender
diversity within uh the industry that
would enable us to be able to identify
best practices and also areas where we
felt there would need to be an
improvement
280 respondents gave us their feedback
on whether gender is a barrier to
progression in the fiber
industry diversion and inclusive
inclusion initiatives and their impact
on organizations
the impact of covid on work life and if
flexible working practices have helped
them balance work and life effectively
i now have the honor to introduce women
and fiber committee member rasheen
mccall rasheen is a senior market and
technology development manager at
corning optical communications and rush
has been our driving force behind the
survey analysis and we'll now be
presenting our four findings so rush the
floor is yours
thank you sue
um
hello um my name is rasheen mccool and
as sue said i work for corning optical
communications
as a senior market and technology
development manager
um but today
i'm here to talk about the women in
fiber gender diversity survey
and before i start i'd like to
um just give some recognition to a
number of people who were had a material
impact
on our ability to deliver this today the
first of course is sue gwaglian
who works for comscope who you've just
heard from she's been a driving force in
the women in fiber committee for the
fiber to the home council europe
um and it's her energy that has pushed
some of these initiatives forward so
um thank you to her
also to patricia rodriguez who is head
of marketing at outvise and sarah grange
who is head of delivery at vx fibre they
also collaborated with me on this survey
i'd like to uh add my personal thanks
to tyga ed and marian edwards at corning
optical communications
um who've
given me the space and empowered me to
pursue
uh some of my interests in this area and
and that's allowed me to give my energy
to this survey um
as it was needed
so
let's
start um
and look at what we're going to talk
about today
so i'm going to talk about the survey
itself and provide just a brief
executive summary of what the findings
were
and then i'm going to dig a little bit
deeper into the data into the questions
and the conclusions
um we're going to look at whether the
fiber industry is a good place to work
whether gender is a barrier to
progression in our industry
our diversity and inclusion initiatives
working
have covered 19 work practices been an
improvement in work life and is there
sufficient flexibility in work practices
but to maintain a work-life balance and
then finally look at the recommendations
uh for the survey
so i'm going to start with the survey
we're going to look at you know what
were the genders of the respondents what
were the ages the 10 years in the
industry and the seniority
and then i'm going to go through some of
our
you know upfront conclusions both the
good good news and the not so good news
uh we put the survey out and we received
280 respondents
uh responses from individuals across
emea
the gender mix of those respondents was
pretty much 50 50.
and now for those of us who've worked in
the industry for a while we know that
our industry isn't 50 50. um gsm did a
survey in 2015 and found that about 20
percent of the industry
was female
and i anticipate that that has improved
over the six years since that survey but
i don't think we're at 50 50. what that
means is that women were more motivated
than men to fill in the survey
and we've taken special care
when we've analyzed the data to take
into consideration
that that 50 50 gender mix doesn't
necessarily
reflect the gender mix in the industry
as a whole
and we had a 50 50 tenure mix that is to
say that about half of the respondents
had less than 10 years
time served in the industry and about
half
more than 10 years
time served in the industry there were
proportionally more women in this
respondent mix that had a shorter tenure
than there were that had a longer
tenure and in terms of age uh the
uh the mix of respondents was dominated
by uh the age group 25 to 56 years old
now of course that's not surprising that
is the the working age life if if you
like and we had about 14
who were older than that 56 years so in
that baby boomer generation and um very
few amongst the next generation that's
coming through
which would be the zoomers or gen z
we also looked at seniority of the
respondents and the way we defined
seniority and is shown here on the left
hand side of this graphic
that we defined seniority in six levels
from level one being entry level
to level six being a business executive
and we accounted for
both managerial seniority but also
expertise in seniority as a technical
industry we know that there are many
individuals at very senior levels that
may not have business responsibility but
do have responsibility in a specific
area of expertise
and we had a pretty good spread across
the respondents
of seniority
and obviously at the lower levels level
one on two that was a higher
proportion of the of the group compared
to the very senior levels but that is
what we would expect given that these
seniority levels go in a kind of pyramid
right
so let's see what
the survey said
well there was a lot of good news for
the industry in this survey
most respondents would recommend a
career in the fiber industry
most said they could be authentic to
themselves
in the workplace
most think that everybody has the same
opportunity to progress in their
organization
most respondents work in organizations
with diversity and inclusion initiatives
and are able to use diversity policies
to report issues related to gender
and most respondents agreed that work
practices during the kovic 19 pandemic
had improved their work lives
this is all good news
and i want us to take away
uh these good news stories uh from this
survey and because i think it's um
i think it's important to know
that that our industry is a place that
people want to work
um
but it's important also to say that not
all experiences are uniform
and the survey brings out with the data
uh some real
uh
characteristics
uh that have a material impact on women
in our industry
so the survey results show and this is
the data that shows that gender is a
barrier to progression
and what i mean by that is that
if i look at the respondents set
i can predict
if somebody is at higher levels of
seniority in our industry
by their gender
and that shows gender bias
that effect materializes later in a
woman's career so it does not obvious
right at the beginning but later on you
start to see the impact
and when we dug into that a little bit
more what we saw was that most men see
no barriers to progression
whereas women see a greater set of
barriers to progression
the survey results show that for every
100 senior business directors executives
and experts that assemble in our
industry there are 12 women missing from
that group and the way i think about
this is if if you were at family wedding
and everybody was sitting down to a
lovely wedding breakfast waiting for the
toasts
that 12 missing women is the equivalent
of
a table at the wedding that is empty
and a whole part of the family that
isn't there
the survey results show that only one in
four respondents had a female line
manager and that had a material impact
on women's access to training and
development and of course what that
means is subsequent opportunity for
women
the survey also showed that one in three
women do not think they have the
flexibility to maintain a work-life
balance and of course over time what
that will do is contribute to attrition
rates of women in the industry
and the survey results show that even in
those organizations with diversity and
inclusion initiatives
one in three respondents did not know
how to report issues related to gender
and that number rises to two in three
when diversity and inclusion initiatives
do not exist now this is important
and the reason this is important
is that
many of the uh of those things
associated
uh with
gender fall into the category
of either duty of care to staff
or statutory compliance in other words
um they that these aspects could be
associated with the legal requirement on
our organizations
and if individuals within those
organizations are not able or don't know
how to report issues related to gender
that leaves organizations in our
industry
open to failures in statutory care
so that's the executive summary so let's
dig into that why did we say that why
have we come to these conclusions well
let's start with is the fiber industry a
good place to work
we asked the question would you
recommend a career in the fiber industry
and the majority of respondents said yes
they could they agreed they would
recommend a career career in the fiber
industry
uh and whilst there were slightly fewer
women than men who who answered
positive to
that question
and the difference wasn't of great
significance
we asked the question do you agree that
you are able to be authentic to who you
are at work
now in the survey we defined being
authentic to who you are
um as the ability to be honest about
personal constraints that impact your
work life or having the confidence to
voice concerns in the knowledge you will
be treated fairly
openly and in a respectful way
again
the majority agreed
there were fewer women the men that
agreed to that statement but not
significantly so
we asked the question do you agree that
everybody has the same opportunity to
progress in your organization and the
majority agreed that yes everybody has
the same opportunity to progress
but in this case
men were significantly more emphatic in
that belief than women in fact there was
a 17
difference
in how many men agreed with that
statement compared to women
so is the fiber industry good place to
work i would say based on these results
yes it is
most people would recommend a career
most people were able to be authentic to
themselves in the workplace the majority
feel that everybody has the same
opportunities for progression
but for every four men who said that
only three women could say the same
and there's a significant minority of
women who are not having the same
positive experiences as their colleagues
so
if
there is some ambiguity as to whether
everybody has the same opportunity to
progress then let's look at progression
let's see if gender is the barrier to
progression in the fiber industry
you'll remember that i showed the
seniority levels that we have defined
and here on this graphic you can see
those seniority levels on the left hand
side
in the center of the graphic in the blue
circles
are the average
distribution of seniority amongst all
respondents so not gendered in any way
and i've then pulled out of this graphic
uh the percentage of men at those
seniority levels
and the percentage of women at those
seniority levels and then compared that
to the average
what you can see is that women are over
represented at the lower levels of
seniority
and under-represented at the very
highest levels and sort of here in the
middle
um they are consistently
under-represented
uh in these middle levels if not at a
very very
great differences
now we went further than that and we
started to look okay what about tenure
how does
the amount of time you spent in the
industry have an impact on this
so the graphic you see in front of you
is for
respondents who said they had a tenure
of less than 10 years experience now of
course not surprisingly with less than
10 years experience we have more
on average more at these lower levels of
seniority than right at the top
and there's some consistency about the
fact that women are underrepresented
here in the middle but but the spread is
so small
i look at this graph and say i can't see
a gender bias here
that is to say i cannot predict where
you sit
on the seniority rankings
if you have a
a tenure of less than 10 years
experience based only on your gender
in fact at level five you can see here
women with less than 10 years gender are
actually
over represented at this level five
level
um
compared to men
so uh there's there isn't i don't see a
lot of gender bias here apart from at
this level five where you could actually
say that women are advantaged
but the picture changes really
significantly when we look at 10 years
of over 10 years
here
the spread of distribution is much wider
between men and women suggesting a
gender bias
and women are over represented at the
lower levels of seniority
and very uh
significantly underrepresented at the
highest levels of seniority
what it appears from this graph is not
only does gender bias exist here
but also women appear to be awarded less
for their long tenure
just to interpret that those results in
another way
and what those results are effectively
saying is there are women that are
missing in action in our industry
um and they're not present in the
numbers expected at senior levels in the
industry
in our industry for every 100 senior
business directors and executives and
experts that assemble there are 12 women
missing from that group
and you can see here
from levels three to six there are women
missing in action
whereas they are overrepresented at the
lower levels
so we didn't just ask kind of yes or no
or data-driven questions we also had
some questions in the survey that were
open
and we wanted people to give us their
input um
and one of the open questions we asked
was
uh what barriers do you have you seen in
your career to progression
now
predominantly what men said was they had
seen no barriers to their progression
whereas
some women said they had seen no
barriers to their progression
and but a large number of women who
responded said that they had seen gender
bias
motherhood not surprisingly was another
uh barrier that they saw to progression
the dominance of male decision makers
and the lack of access to male networks
of
influence were all things that women
felt had been barriers to their
progression
um
now because of this difference in
experience there were a small set of men
who reject the lived experiences of
their female colleagues
entirely
um and so
we did see a number of responses
and
along the lines of i have not seen
anyone experiencing barriers in his or
her career because of his or her gender
there are no barriers of progression for
anyone
and
some one gentleman went as far as to say
i think this topic is totally
exaggerated nonsense
so whilst
it and i think this is associated with
the
non-uniformity of experience not all
women are
experiencing um barriers in their
careers
uh not all men are experiencing barriers
in their career but a few some women
are experiencing gender bias
and and the fact that
the majority don't experience it does
not mean it doesn't happen
so um we also ask the question do you
have a female line manager
and one in four said yes
we said
have you received training in the past
12 months
and just over half said yes they had
received training in the past 12 months
and we correlated those two results
and what we discovered that was that for
those who had a female line manager
on
they were more likely than average
uh to receive training
for those who had a mail line manager
uh the men with the mail line manager
were about as likely as average to
receive training
but women
who had a mail line manager were
significantly less likely
than their male colleagues to retreat
receive training and significantly less
likely than average and certainly
significantly less likely to receive
training
and than if they had a female 1 manager
so gender
not only of the recipient of the
training but also of their line manager
has a material impact on whether women
receive training and that of course has
a knock-on effect to opportunity
so in conclusion gender is a barrier to
progression
um
at senior levels we have women who are
missing in action
um most men experience no barriers to
their progression whilst women
experience some
more
and a broader set
um and there are some men uh who
um who reject the idea that barriers
exist at all because they have not
experienced those barriers
uh one in four
had a female line manager and for female
respondents that had a material impact
on their access to training and
development
as a result of that
uh the women in fiber committee are
offering five recommendations based on
this data
measuring track gender balance in senior
leadership roles
if there is a great disparity there do
something about it
measuring track gender balance in
training
if there is a large disparity there do
something about it
focus on progression for women towards
senior leadership roles during
mid-career because mid-career appears to
be the danger point for women
create gender balance in leadership
development pipelines and access for
women to net male net networks of
influence
initiate unconscious bias training and
opportunities for women to tell their
stories in order to raise consciousness
and just because we have not all
experienced
gender bias
does not mean it doesn't exist
okay next
are diversity and inclusion initiatives
working let's have a look at that
so we asked are diversity initiatives in
place in your organization and
three out four said yes
we also asked do you know how to use
your organization diversity politics
policies to report any issues you have
associated with your gender
and for those
who worked in organizations with
diversity initiatives
um
at least two out of three said yes they
know how to report issues
associated with gender
um
for those who work in organizations that
don't have diversity initiatives
that
proportion dropped dramatically so now
only round about one in three know how
to report issues associated with gender
and that matters
that matters not just for duty of care
but because some of the issues that may
be reported that are associated with
gender
are also is associated with an
organization's statutory compliance
um
and so
um i think this one is something for
managers to consider
do your staff know how to report
and it's really important they do
we also dug a bit deeper into diversity
initiatives um
and we got res uh we got you know um
full text text answers from a number of
respondents
and one gentleman said what is not often
considered in the gender debate is that
male employees often have sisters and
children which they want to have the
same chances in employment
um
and he liked the idea that
that his organization were actively
seeking for female candidates
and if you feel the same if you are a
gentleman
like
this respondent here stand up and be an
ally
where you see
things where things can be improved
stand up and be an ally because it is
individual decisions made on a daily
basis
that will make a difference in moving
the negal
uh on some of the statistics that we've
seen earlier
uh
somebody
an alternative point of view is you know
one gentleman who said to be honest i've
had quite enough of everything to do
with diversity
uh one woman here says i don't believe
we need to do anymore i've never
experienced any issues
clearly other women have experienced in
issues one asks for gender pay gap
reviews
have a policy to start with
uh more policies to refer to when people
step over the line
um
policies
our good controls
um it is in uncontrolled environments
and
that a lot of this gender bias can
really take root
so
three and four respondents work for
organizations that have diversity and
inclusion initiatives great news
having those diversity initiative
initiatives
significantly increase awareness of
diversity policies and that's important
because that means um
that
organizations are complying with the
duty of care to staff
and
statutory care but even in organizations
with diversity and inclusion initiatives
there are a significant number of people
who do not know how to report
they need to be trained because at the
very worst point that leaves
organizations open to failures in
statutory care
so
what are our recommendations based on
these this data
initiate or perpetuate diversity and
inclusion initiatives
train staff on the use of diversity
policies or issue reporting and in
delivering diversity and inclusion
training
recognize that experiences are not
uniform clearly there are individuals in
our
in our industry who are really fed up
of hearing about this topic
and who potentially feel like it's a
criticism of them
it is not
criticism
of
individuals to say there is a gender
bias
is not to say
that
all men are biased
or to say there's a problem with the
system is not to imply criticism of
people within that system
uh it's it's a really important
part of delivering diversity and
inclusion
is that we include everybody in the
conversation
um
and uh just for on behalf of the women
in fiber committee
i would like to say that our committee
wants to include everybody in the
conversation
um we think that's important and we hope
that others within the industry think
that's important too
now let's turn to changes in work
practices and flexibility we asked and
of course we've been through a very
extraordinary
time recently
do you agree that changes in work
practices during the covig-19 pandemic
have been an improvement in your work
life
and the majority said yes
and interestingly enough
gender was not a predictor of that
response men and women answered that
question equally
the other thing
that i looked at was
is that response
um
correlated in some way with caring
responsibilities because we did ask
respondents if they have caring
responsibilities and in fact it's not
um so neither gender nor caring
responsibilities uh had an impact on
that response
but what had a really big impact was age
those
dominant within the industry that is
those between 25 and 56
uh the majority of that gen x and
millennial generation liked the kovid 19
changes
um
the older the oldest and the youngest
amongst the cohort were the least happy
with those changes in work practices
we also asked uh
you know do you feel you're empowered
to take flexible working opportunities
in your organization to maintain a
work-life balance and the majority said
yes
um
women were less likely to feel that way
than men
and there's about
a nine percent difference there in
response
and of course if respondents did not
feel like they were empowered to
to maintain this work-life balance that
is going to have an impact
on attrition rates particularly over the
long term
um when i looked at tenure
um
we had
a 50 difference between the women who
have in our industry have a tenure of
less than five years
and women who have a tenure of more than
21 years
so most respondents agree that changes
in work practices during covig 19 have
made an improvement
in their work lives that was not a
gendered response
the what that response correlated most
closely to was age
the oldest and the youngest in the
industry are least happy
with the changes
the majority of respondents agreed that
they had sufficient flexibility at work
to maintain a work life balance this is
really great news that the majority
think that
women were slightly less convinced so
one in three women don't feel like they
have that flexibility
um and over the long term what is that
is going to inevitably do
is increase attrition rates amongst
women
more than men
so in terms of recommendations based on
that data we would suggest that the work
practices that have been put in place
post uh during the pandemic should be
continued post pandemic
but be aware that the youngest and
oldest in the industry may
prefer more traditional patterns of
working or may need more support
adapting to post-pandemic norms
introduce or expand flexible working
policies the main allow staff to
maintain a work-life balance and reduce
attrition rates of women as tenure
increases
so that's the data um i have kind of
gone through all the recommendations but
i think it's worth
just going through these again
um
unless we measure and track something we
can't improve it and we want to improve
the balance
of women
in senior leadership roles so measure
and track that gender balance
and if you don't like the figures do
something about it
measure and track gender balance in
training
if you don't like those figures do
something about it if you are a manager
um who has responsibility for staff
and have a look at your own decision
making how many women are you putting
through for training compared to the men
in your teams
is that
proportion the same
and if it's not it should be
focus on progression forming towards
senior leadership roles during
mid-career there is a real danger point
for women in the middle of their careers
um and that has an effect later on
create gender balance in leadership
development pipelines
so that we have a
set of women who are being trained and
given the opportunities to flex
um
their managerial muscles so that they
are ready to enter into those leadership
pipelines and take those senior roles
and give access to women to those male
networks of influence
initiate unconscious bias trainings and
opportunities for women to tell their
stories in order to raise consciousness
it's easy to believe that simply because
we have not experienced something
that it is doesn't exist
it does exist women
feel it they may not be the majority of
women even but if there is a significant
minority of women who are not having a
good time in our industry we want to fix
that
initiate or perpetuate diversity and
inclusion initiatives and that's
important because it allows
uh staff to understand what diversity
policies are in place
and perhaps even more importantly than
the initiatives themselves is to train
staff
on the use of diversity policies for
issue reporting make that easy because
that is about a duty of care to staff
and a statutory compliance
and for your organization
in delivering diversity inclusion
training recognize that experiences are
not uniform and the improvement of
system does not imply criticism of
individuals within the system
i'd like to speak directly to
men who may be listening to this who
find the whole topic of diversity and
inclusion uncomfortable
um
discussion of diversity issues does not
imply a direct criticism of men
um i didn't become an engineer
and go into
one of the most male dominated
industries i could find because
because i didn't like men
i mean you know it
i have worked with some incredible men
uh men who are fair who are smart and
who just want to get the job done
and
and
i know that in dealing with a lot of
you know women including women in the
women in fiber committee
we're trying to make the system better
we're not implying criticism of
individuals within that system
uh continue covered 19 work practices
post pandemic but be aware that the
youngest and the oldest in the industry
may not like
or may prefer more traditional patterns
of working and need more support
adapting to post-pandemic norms
and introduce or expand flexible working
policies to allow staff to maintain that
work-life balance
and reduce attrition rates of women as
tenure increases
and i'd like to leave you with this
thought
um
which is from archbishop desmond tutu
there comes a point where we need to
stop just pulling people out of the
river we need to go upstream and find
out why they're falling in um and that
in a sense is the purpose of the survey
to try and look at the root causes of
some of the gender disparity within our
industry
and find ways of improving it
so thank you very much
i'm gonna pause there for questions
thank you very much rosh for such an
impassioned readout i think i've heard
that now for four times maybe and every
time i hear it i pick up more and i
can't help but but being in awe of you
know how passionate you feel about this
and the energy that you've put into this
as a project so a big thank you on
behalf of the ftth council europe for
all of your hard work and the many many
many hours that's gone into creating
this this great body of work and lots of
food before there a huge amount of
content which as i said earlier will be
made available to you um once we've
wrapped the webinar so we do have a few
minutes now left for some questions i'm
starting to see a few questions come in
but as i said earlier don't be shy we'd
love to we'd love to get some
interaction with you um by the q a
um so rush first question that's come in
um
what kinds of training exist to educate
men on gender barriers in the industry
that's a really really good uh that's a
really good question
um
i've been fortunate um
to see a number of uh
trainings now so i think um
there is training from
a lady who used to be at facebook i
can't remember her name but she wrote a
book called lean in uh sh who she has a
company that runs gender bias training
um
there are other companies within europe
who
who specialize in this kind of
unconscious bias training
and so it is out there
um
and
i think it is out there and it is
available
um but also i would say
one of the very best things you can do
for within your organization
is facilitate honest conversations with
your female colleagues
they know
they they definitely know
where
where the issues are in your
organization because they will have
experienced it
and i think as well on on on that point
rush as we identified um a large number
a good percentage of um three out of
four um people uh work for companies
that have dni uh initiatives within
those companies and quite often um those
forums are a great source of content and
development tools that employees can
leverage um both an individual level but
as a manager as well so you know ways in
which they can they can foster that that
more inclusive environment within their
workplace so again if you're fortunate
to work for one of those companies then
then you know become a member get
involved they are what you make of them
you get out of them what you put in
yeah
go for it
i was just about to say yes um
and then
we we had a session
um in the women in fiber session at the
fiber to the home conference in which
tom verbecki talked about male
allies and
you know if we're going to move the
needle on this we
we need to do this together
and clearly i'm very passionate about
this topic but but you know we need male
allies
um and so
i would really encourage you to join
those diversity and inclusion
initiatives
indeed
okay we've got a few more questions ross
so we'll work our way through those um
we've
we sometimes hear hear i guess comments
like this so um you know let's uh let's
take this one on which is um isn't the
main reason women do not advance the
same level as men um it's because they
choose to have children
um i think
i think
yes
that's a significant
uh barrier we saw that in the data right
motherhood was considered as
a barrier to progression and um you know
it seems to me
this
for millennia in fact it's just a fact
of life women
have the babies right we we're the one
who bear the children
um
and
we're the ones who sustain the human
race by bearing children right it's a
necessary part of humanity to do that
but we don't lose our minds after having
children
i mean we are able to function and
contribute after motherhood
um
so
what are the barriers towards
contributing after motherhood
and well that's about work-life balance
it's about flexibility
um
it is clear
that our industry is set up to advantage
those that don't have children
um
and for a very long time
there was a sort of
acceptance
uh that that's just had to be the way
you did it
you know that if you were in a sales
organization you had to be on the road
75 of your time
well we've just lived through a pandemic
and there are lots of sale organizations
that are still selling and their sales
people aren't away from home 75 time
there has been a
assumption that if you lead a team you
have to be in the office in order to
lead that team
well we've just been through a pandemic
in which we weren't able to go into the
office and to my knowledge teams are not
disintegrating
left right and center simply because
they meet
on a video call instead of in the office
we can't change things
um and we should change things because
women do have children and it's a good
job they do
otherwise we wouldn't be here
let's just let's just accept that fact
and
and
you know
accept the fact that our female talent
is likely to get pregnant at some point
um and and adjust our
adjust our organizations to cope with it
because it you know it's a fact of life
and
i think that
some of the
decision-making means that we perpetuate
this lack of opportunity lack of
training for women in those mid-careers
uh because we think they're gonna go off
and have a baby right and um and that
then has a knock-on effect later on it
is also the case that society is
changing
there are women who don't have children
and there are women who
want who don't want children there are
there are women who have partners that
stay at home and look after their
children the world is the changing place
and we shouldn't make assumptions
about the way women
should or will behave simply based on
their gender any more than we should
make assumptions about how men
should or will behave based on their
gender
great response
thank you russian you touched a little
bit there in terms of the the need
for flexible working and obviously we've
been through um a couple of years where
i think companies have uh have adapted
mindsets and and you know
become more open to to flexible and
working from home provisions um we've
had a question that's come in um which
i'll read out now it was mentioned that
men and women equally prefer the
flexibility the pandemic caused in
working from home etc do you have any
insight or view on the leading reasons
of men versus women if there are any
differences to why that
statement applies
now that that's a really good question
we did not ask an open question about
that so we asked the question
you know do you like the working
practices but we didn't go deeper and
ask why
uh i suspect we will be doing another
one of these surveys at some point in
the future and and maybe that's a lesson
for us to go deeper into those questions
so that i'm able to answer that
um
so the data doesn't tell us basically on
on why that is
i was not if i'm honest i wasn't
surprised that it wasn't a gendered
response
because i think that
whether or not you're enjoying working
from home
with less time in the office
probably has a lot more to do with your
role
uh and also whether you're an introvert
or an extrovert which i think is a
personality trait as opposed to a
gendered trait i think some people like
the face to face the energy they get
from a face-to-face interaction
and some people find that exhausting you
know and and that's not a gendered
thing that's a personality type
yeah
yeah and i guess how much other
distractions that individual has in
their home environment i mean you know
many so many colleagues that have had to
contend with you know raising small
children pets jumping on top of them
everything going on while they're still
trying to maintain focus on on
conference calls as well so um
challenging times
okay um another question for you um
from what i can see from the data we've
made some huge strides in the past 21
years doesn't this mean that things are
finally getting better for women in the
workplace
yeah so we had some debate about this
and
um i think this is uh whether you're a
glass half full or a glass half empty
person so
uh i showed can i just go back to these
graphs if i can sorry let me because
it's easier to show you
i do apologize if this is
here we go
okay so
uh this graph which is less than 10
years and this one which is more than 10
years
and there were those that looked at
these graphs and said well that means
that things are getting better
um and there were those that looked at
these graphs and said aha
well that just demonstrates there's a
glass ceiling
uh the fact of the matter is this data
does not show either of those things
there isn't enough
data here to make the leap that says
that
uh
the fact that this is a lower
gender bias than this means things are
getting better
nor is there a sufficient amount of data
to say
uh that this is evidence of a glass
ceiling
um you know because at lower levels
there is no gender bias but at higher
levels there clearly is
and
i was very very disciplined about not
going further than the data would allow
me to go
um
and so the fact that you could take this
data and explain it into
divergently different explanations
demonstrates that you just can't go that
far with this data
great thank you rush we're getting some
lovely comments in by the way so thank
you everyone for your your warm response
there lots of thank yous and um
some suggestions so someone's talked
about um
the lady obviously that you referenced
with cheryl sam
samberg um they received the lean in
netherlands 50 ways to fight bias
uh training via work which they
recommend for for some um training and
development there so thank you very much
for that suggestion um another question
is did we cut the data in any way um by
geography so i.e are there particular
biases between countries
um we didn't cut it
by
geography
um
one of the reasons for that
excuse me was that um
we didn't have
sufficient well
first of all we didn't ask the question
where are you located
and i think the reason we didn't ask
that question uh was twofold really
first of all we were concerned about
slicing the data into too many parts
um and not having a statistically
significant set
we did ask about ethnicity
and
the and perhaps
something i should have said really
is that
in emea our industry is so predominantly
white
that we could not
slice this data by ethnicity because we
simply didn't have a statistically
strong set of any ethnicity that wasn't
white
which is another
so you know that's another aspect of
diversity that we that maybe the
industry needs to think about
and actually someone's asked that
question is would we consider a next
iteration of the survey where we would
perhaps look at citizen status or race
as an extension of that
yeah yeah well i mean we we would have
done it if we could
if i could have done i would have done
yeah but i just didn't have enough
respondents to be able to do it
great okay thank you uh just working our
way through some of these questions
we're getting uh
yes um people asking if we can download
the data absolutely this is all going to
be available to you as a full um
set of material afterwards so um you
know to be able to use and take back to
your companies
um i think we've got time for one more
question rash did you find companies
which have developed career paths
specifically for women taking special
care of elevating their children with
reduced working hours and more flexible
hours
that's talking about best practice so
identifying companies out there who are
doing a really good job and perhaps you
know which i think we're trying to do is
there are people that are really trying
to address this gender balance and
how are they getting it right and what
lessons can we take from them and
perhaps share with a wider audience
so i think the person that asked that
question has just
uh added a task onto the women in fiber
committee task list
i think that's one of the things we want
to do and it's one of our stated aims
which is to share best practice
and we didn't ask
specific uh questions like that in the
survey mainly because we didn't want to
identify organizations specifically
and but you'll notice that a lot of this
is you know we're not calling out
individual organizations or individuals
at all in fact
um uh but when we share best practice
um i think we will do that
and it is something that um
you know what we have i know in corning
we've spoken about this
uh a lot about the
sort of the the fast slow fast
which is which is the nature of a woman
uh particularly if you have children
well it's the nature of a mother's
career
which is you can go fast in early career
until you have a child
and then there's a period where maybe
you've got to sort of level set
but aft when you're ready
then the next thing to do is to go fast
again and we need we need to be able to
do that
indeed
rush i think we could probably have gone
for another 15 20 minutes we've still
got questions in the queue to to answer
so thank you so much for everyone for
being so engaged and interactive that
really means a lot to us so thank you
for the participation again a huge thank
you to rosh if you'd like to to pick up
the discussion with us and continue this
then we will be hosting um a three-hour
workshop at the uh fibre to the home
conference in vienna in in march next
year so what we'll be doing is a blend
of keynotes some panel sessions and then
some round tables discussions as well
and so some of these key themes may well
be uh tabled for for discussion then and
we'd love to see you and uh and get some
input from you then
thank you very much to um our wonderful
presenter rasheen thank you all for
attending we wish you a very happy
holidays and
we'll see you in 2022. thank you very
much
bye
bye